[Music]
a lot of new information tonight just in
here at five on bamboo the bulldog who
died after being taken from his yard now
two arrests have been made in this case
victoria saha joining us in studio in
victoria we also know how the dog died
yeah bamboo died of blunt force trauma
and respiratory distress 36-year-old
diego gonzalez was arrested wednesday
facing charges of larceny and animal
abuse now the family of bamboo was
notified within the past hour of a
second person arrested the dog
disappeared june 6. there's surveillance
video and now the company's owners also
on new video trying to compensate
bamboo's family bamboo's family says
this surveillance video changed
everything after they realized bamboo
didn't just run away workers are seen
putting bamboo in a white truck minutes
later the truck drives away
bambooz family says that is diego
gonzalez the same man you see in
surveillance video getting into the
white truck where bamboo was put in
family of bamboo confronted the men who
kept denying they had the dog did it die
in the car because it was too hot yes no
you
the other men not saying much either
were choosing to blur their faces
because they have not been charged in
this case you need to go get the dog
you know where that dog is
you need to go get it
bamboo's body was found the next day in
north las vegas in the aliante area
gonzalez owns the flooring company with
his wife she is heard being upset with
the situation
to get
company voting
for your nice stupid mistakes i can do
to make you ride on my car like i told
you
it said give you guys
during the last couple weeks since our
report first aired the gonzalez family
kept denying their involvement in an
email statement they say in part i
sympathize with the owners it was wrong
of those men to take the dog and drop it
off inside the community but my family
and i do not have any direct involvement
on thursday i went to the gonzales
residence we're trying to be fair and
give diego a chance to talk they got
what they wanted get off my property now
according to an arrest report for
gonzales it says he was responsible for
taking bamboo away from any chance of
making it home to safety which
ultimately led to bamboo dying in a
malicious and torturous way gonzalez
returns to court next month brian